where is she a suspected drunk driver
speeds around other cars as you can see
slamming into a mother and grandmother
now she is nowhere to be found
this is a story you will only see right
here on eight news now and our eight
news now i-team's david sharon is here
with how prosecutors warned the driver
may skip court and why the victim's
family says she deserves no more chances
david denise and brian gilmo
rodriguez-walters was on her way home
from work when police say that driver
you just saw marcia byrd slammed into
her car killing her there is now a
warrant out for her arrest simply
because no one can find her how do you
plead to those two charges
not guilty
the person you hear there is marcia byrd
she's the defendant in this 2020 court
hearing held via video conference months
earlier another camera caught her
allegedly driving under the influence
here near tropical parkway in torrey
pines my daughter is seven years old and
she still cries for grandma gilmore
rodriguez-walters died in the december
2019 crash investigators taking these
photos of her t-boned car police say
bird was passing other cars when she'd
lost control of hers and flipped ruth
neal rodriguez walter's daughter lives
out of the country and i want to say my
mom died on impact just keep in contact
with your attorney miss bird okay
yes
thank you but now more than two years
later no one seems to know where marsha
byrd is she was due in court last month
didn't show now this warrant is out for
her arrest she should be in prison she
should be
suffering the consequences for this i
mean
but she's not
so
where is she neal wants to know how bird
was led out of jail in the first place
prosecutors say bird is a four-time
convicted felon who violated her alcohol
monitoring after the crash so the
state's asking for a hundred thousand
dollars during this court appearance
after that violation bird's lawyer
argued she was undergoing chemotherapy
and that alcohol in her system could be
from the hair products she was using
prosecutors had warned in documents that
due to the evidence and the quote
likelihood of conviction bird was a
flight risk judge douglas herndon
keeping byrd's bail at 25-thousand
dollars if there's any more problems and
i have to remand you to custody i can
guarantee you you are not going to get
health care that you need while you're
in the detention center herndon ordering
her not to drive and to undergo drug
monitoring little did i know she still
had her driver's license up until that
point it's a failure in whatever is
happening in
the legal system
in las vegas right neal says she and her
family were looking forward to court
last month a time she says would finally
bring her mother justice where's marsha
i want to fight marcia
if i was in vegas right now i'd be
looking for her myself
well if found bird would be taken to
jail and held without bail we reached
out to both her lawyer and that judge
who by the way is now on the nevada
state supreme court we did not receive a
response denise well david our viewers
can help by submitting any tips to crime
stoppers at the number right there on
your screen 702-385-55
you can also report tips anonymously
anytime online as well and we have a
link to that on our website